riot games and its ceo are being sued
for workplace harassment
and gender discrimination the recently
filed complaint caps off a years-long
investigation
into an allegedly toxic workplace the
gaming giant has been sued for both of
these things before
as well as allegedly firing women who've
decided to speak out
riot says they've made a lot of changes
since the allegations were made
but this complaint begs to differ on
february 9th
a legal complaint was filed by former
riot employee sharon o'donnell
against the company and her former boss
ceo nicolo laurent
i say complaint because there is a
difference between a legal complaint and
a lawsuit
a complaint refers to all of the
documents filed explaining the
allegations
while a lawsuit refers to the actual
legal proceedings that take place in
court
o'donnell was hired as laurent's
assistant in october of 2017
and was eventually fired in july of
2020. the complaint alleges that
throughout her time working for riot
o'donnell experienced multiple instances
of harassment and gender discrimination
quote shortly after the plaintiff was
hired the defendant laurent
began a pattern of harassing the
plaintiff based on her sex
or gender this continued until the end
of her employment end quote the
complaint includes a laundry list of
specific allegations
one of which is an instance where
laurent allegedly asked o'donnell to
come over to his house
while his wife and kids were away note
the spelling
the complaint alleges that laurent
constantly demeaned o'donnell and
references a time where laurent was
allegedly
quote staring at her in a sexual fashion
when discussing his underwear
while telling the plaintiff that he
really was a size extra large
but that he just liked a tight fit end
quote
on top of that the complaint alleges
that o'donnell was forced to work
overtime she was never paid for
and rarely was given her legally
mandated work breaks
the complaint also states that once she
refused laurent's advances and went to
hr to complain about his behavior
her work duties were stripped away and
she was eventually fired the complaint
says that by not paying her for her
overtime work and not giving her her
legally manded work breaks
riot violated the fair employment and
housing act or fia
in the united states and if you didn't
know fia was passed in 1959
to help fight against sexual harassment
and other forms of
unlawful discrimination in employment
and housing the complaint also alleges
that riot games as a company
failed to take all of the necessary
steps to stop this alleged behavior
and essentially just ignored everyone
who came forward to talk about it
according to the complaint things got so
bad for o'donnell that she had to seek
out medical attention
quote as a further and proximate result
of the discrimination as a four pled
the plaintiff was required to and did
seek medical attention
and will need medical attention in the
future end quote now
o'donnell's experience that we've been
talking about so far is not an isolated
incident
in fact this story goes all the way back
to 2018.
in august of 2018 kotaku published an
in-depth investigation into the
workplace culture of
riot by speaking to 28 current and
former employees
the investigation was able to highlight
a series of systemic issues
relating to alleged sexism harassment
and abuse of power by management in
particular the piece describes a
workplace where women were consistently
turned down for leadership positions
as well as a list that was allegedly
passed around by senior management
describing women at the company they'd
like to sleep with by november of 2018
a few months after the original story
broke one current
at the time and one former riot employee
filed a class-action lawsuit against the
company
alleging systemic gender discrimination
developer surveys
consistently find that discrimination
and sexism
are endemic to the gaming industry but
understand how bad it's gotten
we have to look at one company in
particular that is
crushing it on the sexism leaderboard
riot games just can't escape
controversy this week the league of
legends developer was slammed with a
class-action lawsuit claiming that the
company fosters a sexist work
environment
in the ensuing aftermath of the
reporting and the class action lawsuit
riot went into full-on crisis mode they
rolled out a bunch of diversity
initiatives on their website
and basically said hey we're not
actually women hating douchebags
this continued into 2019 as riot doubled
down on the whole
or changing promise but the thing that
made this go international and caused
one of the biggest walkouts that the
games industry has ever seen
was something called forced arbitration
which is a tactic designed to stop
employees suing for all sorts of
workplace violations
including gender discrimination and
harassment it works like this if an
employee files a workplace lawsuit
against their employer
forced arbitration makes it so that
there's no public trial
instead a company hires a private
litigator to reach a settlement behind
closed doors
away from any public spotlight it's a
pretty nefarious tactic that companies
like google have stated that they've
stopped using
not riot games though because in april
of 2019 almost
eight months after that original kotaku
investigation
riot filed a motion blocking employees
from suing them for harassment
in other words forced arbitration
according to riot at the time the
argument was simple
as soon as these women were hired they
waived any right to sue
on may 6 2019 riot games employees and
other games industry employees from
around the world
staged a gigantic walkout in protest of
riot's forced arbitration policies
and the entire situation as a whole we
reported on this at the time
in one of the very early episodes of
this show
over the past few months riot games has
been under a ton of criticism
current and former employees have
accused the company of fostering a toxic
sexist workplace culture and breaking
california labor laws
which all led to a walkout last month
and based on how it went
we're in for a lot more action in
response to the walkouts
riot announced they'd be changing their
policy on forced arbitration
sort of quote ultimately given the
complexities of ongoing litigation
we will not change our employee
agreements while in active litigation
everything we've heard will impact our
discussions when we revisit arbitration
and we hope to have an answer that would
be satisfying to everyone
at a minimum we will give new riders the
option to opt out of arbitration on
individual sexual harassment claims
end quote so what riot essentially said
here was hey
if you're currently suing us because
we're shitty well
tough luck but in the future if you sue
us for being shitty well then we won't
force you into closed-door arbitration
on top of that wishy-washy statement
riot announced a new diversity and
inclusion department with the goal to
quote
leverage a group of engaged and
thoughtful writers from teams across the
company
to participate in formal discussions on
d and i
end quote all of this was happening
throughout the summer of 2019
and by december of that same year the
class action lawsuit that was filed in
2018
finally came to an end a court ordered
riot to pay out 10 million dollars
spread out amongst every woman who had
worked for riot in the past
five years and according to one of the
plaintiff's lawyers at the time
this settlement was one of the largest
in california history for gender
discrimination lawsuits
from there things died down for a while
and everyone hoped that riot was taking
their diversity initiative seriously
which brings us back to now
almost two years later on the cusp of
another lawsuit
alleging the same sexist behavior this
time
leveled at the ceo of the company and in
terms of a resolution
o'donnell is looking for compensation
over the lost wages from the
overtime she worked as well as damages
stemming from the emotional
and mental health turmoil she
experienced while working for riot and
laurent
now i reached out to riot for a
statement about this whole situation
and here's what they had to say quote in
this case
because some of the claims relate to an
executive leader
a special committee of our board of
directors is overseeing the
investigation
which is being conducted by an outside
law firm our ceo has pledged his full
cooperation and support during this
process
and we're committed to ensuring that all
claims are thoroughly explored
and appropriately resolved one subject
we can address
immediately is the plaintiff's claim
about their separation from riot
the plaintiff was dismissed from the
company over seven months ago
following more than a dozen complaints
from both employees
and external partners and after offering
multiple coaching discussions to try and
address these concerns
any suggestion otherwise is simply false
end quote so almost two years later have
things
actually changed at riot they would
argue yes
pointing to multiple diversity
initiatives that they've started
but it's a pretty rough look when the
ceo
of the very company that says it's
changing for the better
is being accused of the exact same
things that caused one of the biggest
walkouts in the history of the games
industry
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you